we come to love them in television and
in movies and on Brooklyn nine-nine
that's back and on NBC just like
America's Got Talent the champions that
he hosts but long before all that he was
an 11th round selection in the 1991 NFL
Draft good to see you Terry Crews real
it is a crazy journey you have taken sir
crazy crazy we have talked about it
before in previous show but I want to
unpack it a little bit here so you were
the out of Western Michigan rights right
I was gone are you from the state of
Michigan I'm from Flint Michigan
born and raised okay walked on as a
football team had a $500 art scholarship
to Western - Western Michigan okay but
you know after a year and a half earned
my scholarship and went on and got
drafted in the NFL which was crazy I was
an athlete man I was actually a
defensive end in college okay really
small 225 you know what I mean just
playing against all these big guys so
you had something like Freeney randall
like spin moves bullrushes this man but
I was I actually was on a strength team
like all you know what is it the
national strength team I literally
broken you know power clean in records
and different stuff if I was a strong
athlete lifted oh my god I know I
probably
I had a 420 bench but I ran a for 540
come on
I was an athlete that was the thing I
mean the only thing you got but this is
the thing I couldn't catch I couldn't I
couldn't throw right I could just
literally take tremendous amounts of
pain that was my ability I could really
run my head into anything and that got
me on three teams over seven seasons
seven years but I was on the Rams
Packers charges Redskins he was just
jumping all around with my wife and kids
line fire like you're gonna ride flier
and the NFL Europe League but before we
get tired like I'm looking here so what
was your draft day like were you home
just I was home and I thought oh my god
I'm gonna I'm gonna go drive did like
third round cuz you know all that all
athletes have to have this you know a
tremendous amount of entitlement and
hubris in order to get going
and my wife was like I don't think it
good and I was like no no baby don't say
it don't say it I'm gonna go third round
checking around man we waited all day
and I had a barbecue all the people they
went home they will see you tomorrow you
know and then the next day happen that's
back when you had to drive in a couple
days yep and uh oh my god I thought I'm
I'm out I didn't get drafted I remember
listen to me I was sitting on my steps
of my mom's house crying literally tears
and my wife was like hey hey she
literally grabs me she said listen this
is your dream this is what you always
wanted to do you know what you're gonna
go free agent you're gonna do what you
got to do but you are gonna wake up and
you're not gonna just feel sorry for
yourself
and you're gonna make sure you get this
shot and you know what happened the
phone rang I thought this rap was over
and it was it the phone rang it was the
LA Rams they said you've been drafted in
the 11th round I was like this is the
thing man you can never give up because
you think it's over and it was not over
you so do you remember who was on the
phone
Ronnie Jones Ronnie Jones linebacker
coach for the LA where had the LA ran
never forget it man so in 91 was
Dickerson still there oh no no that was
John Roberts it was the coach right Jim
Everett was a I backed up Kevin green I
was Kevin greens back calm on amazing
the best people in the world let me tell
you man
What's Up daddy was up dude come on over
here buddy let's do he literally talk
like a wrestler all the time but he was
so encouraging and he was 80 it what's
up man do you think man he was in Jackie
Slater it was on the team I got to
working but because it was like going in
that locker room now I have to say the
NFL was a little bit different there
yeah I remember walking into the locker
first thing I saw was a guy smoked it
he's like hey man
lock it over there man
I like what this happen that was 91 you
know what I mean that was old-school you
know yeah it was people were real man
they were real 91 93 and then you were
the charges in 94 does that mean you
were on the Super Bowl team did you go I
know I didn't I got cut I was in the I
got cut by the Packers okay
picked up two days later in the 93
season okay and signed with the Chargers
spent all year with Bobby Ross Junior
Seau Gary Plummer just all Stan
Humphries was a quarterback you know and
then I came back the next year and got
cut and listen this was this was the
twisted part hmm is that my my
linebacker coach I'm blanking on his
name right now but he asked that I stay
in town because they were gonna bring me
back the Chargers it discharges and so
all 94 I waited all season and sat there
and spent my own money to stay in San
Diego and they went all the way to the
Super Bowl hunted and they didn't bring
me back he kept calling me every week oh
the pain was incredible when I tell you
how to watch them go to the Super Bowl
and to think that okay next week they're
gonna pick me up next week he told me he
called me it was really really hard man
now that was probably one of the most
depressing periods of my entire life it
got dark so what kept you going Terry
Crews again I mean you know what I'm
from Flint man and to me it was like
well what am I gonna do go back you know
I mean literally what what was there in
Flint Michigan for me I mean you can see
it now you know you're like man all the
city the whole city is going getting
raised and it was drugs it was crazy you
couldn't even drink the water so what is
there for me so I was like I might as
well just keep going forward it was one
of those things where you know you have
to burn the boats you know what I mean
you come over and you just burn the boat
I'm gonna stay here and we got to make
it work and you got to fight the winner
and it gets cold and let me tell you my
wife was with me man that was the best
part about it she was like 100% whatever
you want to do I'm going to support you
what's your name it's great Rebecca my
wife for but she's here
she did that's my sweet thirty years if
she is right there on the riches and
show green room counselor you've seen at
all let's give her let's give her a
little bit of run over there so all
right when did you decide that's it and
I want to try something else
you know I remember I got picked up by
the Philadelphia Eagles right after my
stint with the Redskins uh-huh and I was
picked up for the playoffs and we lost
to the 49ers in 97 early in January it
was a wild card game we lost and then I
got a tryout at San Francisco and I
remember feeling being treated I just I
remember just feeling so off and
terrible it's got through this ball at
me so hard my finger was bent backwards
and he was just like come on man and I
just was like I had enough like there
was a moment I had a Vontae Davis moment
what's that when you just say I'm done
now his was a half-time I got something
to say about this I love this go for it
people really what bothers me is that
with football
Vontae Davis was seen as some kind of
disappointment and it was hard but then
we tell you he actually had it together
he actually realized there's someone
better that needs to be out here you
know I mean I can't give what I need to
give and I think as a in any workplace
if you can't give what you need to give
the best bet is to let someone else take
that spot and he was demonized and it
was kind of scary because people
actually tried to say they would fight
him for that and I said you know
football is a game football is not war I
mean I can get it if you leave a guy in
a bunker in war but if you leave the
army softball team is that dangerous you
know what I'm saying so I guess people
were saying Terry Crews here in the Rich
Eisen show is that if Vontae Davis it
was a road game he would have had he
wouldn't have done what he did right
that it was convenient that his car was
right in the parking lot and he left and
that he should have at least stayed the
second half of that game but if you're
out there on the field and you know
you've got zero left listen first of all
I
I when I my first year as a rookie I
remember when my Utley broke his neck
broke his neck for the LA Rams Detroit
we were in Detroit he broke his neck and
never walked again hip he had a feeling
right before that that I should stop you
gotta respect it you're suing I mean
like we were talking like paraplegic
forever
hmm and he came to he gives thumbs up
and a whole thing but maybe if my Utley
had got this thing where he said you
know what I should stop I should stop
you have to heed that as any human being
any person sometimes you get a little
spidey sense where you say man you know
what maybe I shouldn't be standing here
right now and the light falls you have
to respect it and when bhante got that
feeling he was like I gotta get out of
here something could happen who knows
what could have happened in that second
half a lot of people like to say oh yeah
you should have done this in it but you
cannot speak for other people that way
well being around the NFL as long as
I've been fortunate to be around Terry
Crews again here on on the Richardson
show is that part and part of Vontae
Davis what he did there was a lot of
people who said he ran he was a coward
or whatever to me leaving the NFL and
trying to figure out what to do next
is a frightening venture for 100% of NFL
players it's really included I mean you
know I worked with Marshall Faulk for
years he's one of my good friends to
this very day and virtually every hit
running back that's about to be draft in
the NFL would sign a sign on a piece of
paper if they could have Marshall Fox
life it's right in contract right or his
career right okay and he had to figure
out at age 32 33 what to do next
fit right and so you what you have been
able to do with your post-playing career
is remarkable what would the Terry Crews
that you just talked about playing
football think of the Terry Crews is
sitting here right now Wow you know I
there was a moment when you have to come
to the realization that the game is over
and that's hard it's really really hard
you got to understand two football
players don't live long
simply because you put everything into
the game you put everything into it and
it's over it feels like a betrayal I
don't care how good you are you know it
really feels like what this is it like
what's next and I have to tell players
all the time I'm 50 years old but I tell
them all the time that the beginning of
your life is when the game ends and I
had to tell myself non-stop while I was
in LA sweeping floors trying to find a
way I told myself my best days are still
ahead of me I had it written down on my
mirror written down I would write it in
notebooks every time I felt doubt I
would say my best days are still ahead
of me and this belief is what feels you
but what happens is is if everyone wants
to talk about that Super Bowl back in 94
but it's okay what I'm saying is they
they treat you as if you that was it but
the deal is is that you have so much
Mike left there's so many things left
man and well I I never got this
realization better than when I started
to travel I started to do movies all
over the world I'm in South Africa I'm
in I'm in Europe I'm in you know I'm in
Hong Kong and they never heard an NFL
mm-hmm and they're looking at me like
you're a star you just need it and I'm
go the world is bigger than this now I
have to say this to a farmer
everything's about farming mmm you know
I'm saying it's all about are we gonna
get that corn but you leave the farm
world and you go to San Francisco and
you go to the cheque company you go
you're not thinking about the corn you
start to experiment and see that wow
there's much more than this and I tell
NFL guys all the time use that ability
use your skill that everything that that
stick-to-itiveness that that that grit
use it in another form and be prepared
because your life still goes on Terry
Crews here on the Rich Eisen show
America's Got Talent the Champions
Mondays at 8:00 Eastern Time and this is
a folks from all over the world and all
them I guess fill in the blank country's
Got Talent as well as some of the
champions and successful folks from
America's
talent too how you enjoying hosting like
you just doing this sort of story but
you know I call myself the Bulge axes of
entertainment yeah you could host didn't
you jump over and do your show it feels
the same so hosting is a hobby I can
only imagine when Bowl go and play
baseball as highest-level get on a plane
and then go play yeah football that's
how I feel I'm literally on the set of
the number one show on TV right now
America's Got Talent
I mean the ratings just came out number
one thing right and then I literally get
my car and go over to Brooklyn nine-nine
which is literally the top sitcom in the
world right now and I go my god this is
what bo must have felt this is how I
felt but I got no concussions and I got
no injuries my knees are good dude my
shoes are great your shoot game is tight
[Laughter]
remember we did battle them a show that
was kind of like American Gladiators
meets WWE team in a cage it was a no
game fight contestant that was my first
job in entertainment period yeah that
was like my first job is in an a - do
you remember him Terry not even joking
no it's all good come on rich he's down
me Terry they always doubt me because
I've had a crazy career as an audio guy
but that was 20 years ago that was 1999
it is 2019 and dare to say I'm in better
shape now I want to play celebrity true
or false with you Terry Crews with some
stuff from some previous interviews of
yours and an on IMDB pages and stuff I
want to know what's true and what's not
let's do true celebrity true or false
with Terry Crews
true even it real true false Terry Crews
your first job was as a sketch artist
for a local news station in the 80s true
or false that is true very very true my
first job my father took me to WDIV TV
12 Detroit and yes exactly
wait he took me now that's another deaf
GRT excuse me JIT TV 12 and Flint
Michigan okay took me down there during
my my summer of my freshman year he was
like hey man you need a job and my son
can draw and they were like oh boy well
you know what and I showed him my
portfolio kay and what they did we I
started sketching for the station and
they put me on the worst murder case in
Flint Michigan history I was in the
courtroom I did the courtroom sketches
and it was but it was a learning
experience for me and it was my first
job in entertainment first job period
but it's also an entertainment course
did you see the sketch artist that from
the deflategate oh come on now well he
gives everybody a bad name it's a sketch
artist
ah you're known for your physique true
or false you have a mean sweet tooth
anyway oh you're sweet too oh yes yes
definitely that's true true what's your
weakness oh my god I have cronuts man
any first of all doughnuts dude donate a
pint of donut I me an apple fritter come
on man
great to be down like oh but you always
regret it you always good but you know
what also I learned to eat not to eat
emotionally this is the thing I've been
doing intermittent fasting so okay it
keeps me away from doughnuts but when I
get depressed and you know you're sad
you didn't get a roll you want it I'm
driving I notice all the donut stores
you know and you realize that you're
trying to placate you know what I mean
you like this doughnut and my wife will
see me eating doughnuts she's like what
happened baby what happened
life is an exact opposite reaction when
she sees sees meeting a donut like what
are you doing you know like she's mad
because well she knows it
I won't look like Terry Crews difference
here yeah that's right I still have time
okay never too late so what is your have
you know have you found out what your
metabolism rate is have you checked on
you know I've done everything man my
ideal is for me I've been intermittent
fasting for six years okay
and it's really giving me a new lease on
life I started to stop eating at ten I
do an eight-hour window 16-hour pass and
it really because you know only thing
that makes you fat as insulin that's it
and if you control your insulin if you
control when that stuff kicks in and
then in peak it I find that you can
really really lose the weight and it
keeps and stay strong are you're also
working out two hours man another one
you worked on a set as a bodyguard for
kube before he cast you on Friday after
next not true story now that's true but
the bodyguard sounds sexy okay it was
security guard like I had a t-shirt with
the flashlight bodyguard sounds like
suits and all that no no it was no I was
like watching cubes car you know hey man
make sure my car stays there like yes
sir you see and I have my batteries but
this thing I made sure all my little
like polo shirts were really tired up
good honest medium all smedium shirts
and they were like looks so amazing and
then he cast you then he put you in and
then he put me in Friday after the next
he remembered me and I had actually did
a spit on training day like extra I was
an extra in training day right and he
remembered me he was like that's the guy
just cute Oh next Friday and put me in
Friday afternoon whoa are you what was
your what was your role in training day
oh I was a uncredited gang member that
was it I was walked on a set to
Washington's at work and the director
Antoine Fuqua said hey man you know what
I don't put you in this movie you down I
was like okay okay so he said take your
shirt off
I took my shirt off and I was the guy on
the roof it was uh pigeons and the whole
thing is Denzel came down just walked on
the set I see Denzel work
I had a friend who were who was like a
location guy denied doing security yeah
and he was like man you wanna watch this
held and I was like yep see this is the
thing a lot of your success just comes
from proximity you know what I mean you
can be broken air I decided to be broke
in LA a lot of great things happen you
know
last one for you Terry Crews you have
never taken a single acting class true
or false
that's true never taken a come-on ever
all my ability all my skill was
on-the-job training and I would mess up
I would mess up bad but this is the
thing everybody messes up right that's
what I used to think you could never
miss a line you know I will watch the
biggest superstar actor get it can I get
another one you like Hey mess up because
you have this myth that you said to be
perfect right and perfection is not
expected only thing you need to do is be
faithful that's it faithful forget
perfection and forget it but if you're
faithful you gonna get this you are the
man Terry Crews I could not be more
happy for your success everybody that
I've known a ton of people in this town
that know you and they all speak
glowingly of you about what a good
person you are think and how all your
success is deserved and and I you come
back any time things I love it at Terry
Crews on Twitter I follow and also on
Instagram and check out America's Got
Talent the Champions Mondays at 8:00
Eastern Time and then of course Brooklyn
nine-nine on Thursday nights on NBC to
watch the po Jackson of the
entertainment industry he's hosting it's
a hobby is a profession that's Terry
Crews here on the Rich Eisen show we're
back with your phone calls and Andrew
Whitworth of the Rams will be another an
actual current Los Angeles wrath we got
to get it if he's here right now we got
to get a Rams reunion with Terry Crews
way better than we used to be homework
amazing he's amazing Terry Crews here on
the Rich Eisen show the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience